hi I'm Kristen Goodwin on this episode
of the Fox News rundown president Trump
signs an executive order addressing
police reform amid mounting pressure for
law enforcement overhauls in the wake of
George Floyd's death former Boston
police chief Daniel Linsky discusses how
he feels the commander-in-chief's
actions will impact law enforcers and
concerns over their practices and from
tensions at home to tensions overseas
Ian Bremmer president of Eurasia Group
and g0 media joins the rundown to break
down to a troubling military clashes one
between North Korea and South Korea the
other at the India China border plus
commentary from national security
analyst Rebecca grant the Fox News
rundown is a Daily News podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast player by going to
FoxNews podcast.com jason Chaffetz I'm
Katie Pavlich I'm Steve Doocy and this
is the Fox News rundown
Wednesday June 17 2020 I'm Dave Anthony
what happened in Atlanta led to more
calls for policing reform but we still
don't know if the officer who shot ray
sharp Brooks will be charged the last
thing you want to do is make a decision
that we're going to charge someone
without appropriate facts and then we
have circumstances with it the charge
doesn't go forward if found not guilty
and we've got further tension to the
community because they feel like you
know the system didn't work again
Alisa Brady it might seem like the whole
world is hyper focused on coronavirus or
protests but certain world leaders still
have other agendas and they're stirring
the pot I mean the United States it does
care a lot less about these crises than
we did historically and I'm dr. Rebecca
grant I've got the final word on the Fox
News rundown
was what many of us watched on video a
murder I think you've had too much to
drink to be driving so chance on your
back boy
that's body cam footage of race shark
Brooks being arrested in Atlanta Friday
night after he was found asleep in his
car at a Wendy's drive-thru he resisted
they grabbed the officers taser you've
probably seen the surveillance video of
a chase broke sporting something and
then shots fired and Brooks ended up
dead
the mayor Keisha Lance bottom says it
was murder it's very clear that our
police officers are to be guardians and
not warriors within our communities the
Brooks family is now waiting for the
district attorney to decide perhaps as
soon as today whether charges will be
filed dealing with the father of four
that's gone a husband a brother a son so
it's a lot of heartache and pain and
confusion on what is just family
attorney Chris Stewart was also asked at
a Fox interview about Brooks
resisting arrest you know George flow
was in handcuffs
and was peel so I don't know if that
triggered him up I'm about to get put in
handcuffs and be helpless and I'll
rather try and get away then be
handcuffed and die like George Roy did
the officer who opened fire was fired
the city took swift action at the
earthing of the mayor against the
officer who fired the actual sauce
officer Garrett roll Fox correspondent
Jonathan Serrie talked to us from
outside the Wendy's which was burned
down by protesters the parking lot now a
makeshift memorial for Rashard Brooks
there was a fellow officer who was also
trying to assist with B&S who did not
open fire but was involved with this
attempted arrest that that clearly went
wrong
Devin Brosnan he's been placed on
administrative leave while the
investigation continues the district
attorney Paul Howard says that he's
awaiting results from ballistic tests
before he's able to complete his
investigation obviously the police chief
has resigned over what happened what's
next for the police force
yeah Erica Scheels has she submitted her
resignation Saturday when shortly after
the video of the incident became public
she had tried to guide the police force
the role of the protests in in downtown
Atlanta had to deal with an earlier
controversy in which yet two black
college students who apparently were
unaffiliated with the protests who got
tased when officers approached their car
and then after this came she offered the
her resignation to the mayor and the
mayor except that the chief issued a
statement saying that it was time for
the city to come together and to work on
uniting law enforcement with people that
they serve another longtime member of
the Atlanta Police Department is serving
as the interim chief of the city is
launched an immediate search a
nationwide search for a new police chief
who obviously is going to have his or
her work cut out for them as they try to
not only maintain order in this city
that is for the first time in year seen
heavy damage during these protests this
is a city that prides itself on peaceful
protests so what we're seeing now is
completely new to us as longtime Atlanta
residents but also uniting a city and
uniting communities with a police force
that many people and minorities can
minority communities don't trust from
Jonathan Serrie in Atlanta we take you
to the White House Rose Garden we need
to bring law enforcement and communities
closer together not to drive them apart
president Trump unveiled an executive
order to reform policing we must improve
accountability increase transparency and
invest more resources in police training
recruiting and community engagement this
after the president met with families of
victims who died in encounters with
police I can never imagine
your pain or the depth of your anguish
but I can promise to fight for justice
for all of our people the order would
create a certification for best
practices for use of force collecting
shared data on officers accused of
misconduct and bring in social workers
to help police in cases like mental
illness and homelessness the Democratic
leader of the Senate Chuck Schumer
called the order modest and unable to
make up for years of inflammatory
rhetoric and trump policies designed to
roll back progress Schumer says real
change is in the bill House Democrats
are working on with four weeks to go in
this current session we have asked
leader McConnell to commit to a vote on
the justice and policing Act before July
4th back to what happened in Atlanta and
the big question was the use of force
criminal so I don't have all of the
information that's necessary to make
that evaluation I can tell you when I
saw the Floyd video it was obvious way
to the beginning that that was quite
clear that that was a criminal act and
probable cause existed Daniel in skis
former superintendent and chief of
police in Boston now managing director
with Kroll what we go in this is Graham
V Connor it's the law of the land a
Supreme Court decision we're officers
it's not do you know Cindy Olinsky I
don't you know I would come with the
hindsight of 20/20 I probably wouldn't
have taken that shot but I don't know
what the officer knew I didn't see what
the officer saw and I didn't have the
ability to process through their eyes
and that's what the Supreme Court says
is what is the reasonable person who's
in that offices facts and circumstances
that particular day that time what's
their decision to utilize force
ordinarily law enforcement can use one
level of force above the level force
they are engaged with tasers are an
incapacitating weapon they are a level
of force above a baton above an OC spray
but but under a firearm they certainly
are
you know non-lethal is how we describe
them however we have seen lethal
occurrences occur with tasers across the
country where they interfere with the
electrophysiology the heart and we've
had people die if you're by yourself
it's a different decision than an
officer who's got another officer who's
with
so I'm sure the disc attorney will weigh
that fact in an officer who's being
tased by themselves could be
incapacitated thus giving them the
inability to protect their weapon and
and and subject to having a weapon taken
from them and we've seen offices had
their weapons stripped out of their
holsters and murdered by them so all of
those facts have to be taken into
consideration and it's not what I think
by looking at a video it's what the DA
can get from witnesses statements from
the individuals involved the forensics
in the physical evidence there that has
to be involved in making the decision
here I think we want to the last thing
we want to do is make a decision that
we're going to charge someone without
appropriate facts and then we have
circumstances where the the person is
you know the charge doesn't go forward
they found not guilty and we've got
further tensions in the community
because they feel like you know the
system didn't work again obviously
second-guessing Monday morning
quarterbacking is a part of every one of
these cases there was a talk of an
eternal family attorney he was like
listen they could have just let him go
they had his ID they could have gotten a
middle later time
that's one element of this and and and
another element of this is that the the
police why don't they just shoot him in
the leg
shoot him in the arm that's something
that gets talked about a lot but that's
not something you guys train right yeah
that's not how you train um United
States Marine I'm an expert shot I've
you know been very successful in every
paper target I've ever encountered
during going to the range having been
involved in the discharge of my fire I
might going to show you that the round
doesn't go exactly where I want it to go
when I'm running the suspects running my
heartbeat is to win a hundred and sixty
beats per minute and I'm out of the
stress and in my amygdalas been hijacked
we have auditory exclusion sight
exclusion we so as far as I was taught
at the police academy we were told that
if an individual is subject to being
arrest and we've decided to take him
into arrest that they have to be
arrested right there is no ability to
resist an unlawful arrest
could they have flee and got him later
sure could he have looked around and got
back in the car and then been you know
in a vehicle where he was unable to
operate it safely
absolutely and police officers have been
involved and settled at civil litigation
and we've seen tragedy
we're you know drunk drivers have been
let go they try to use discretion Park
them tell them to come back another day
and the driver sneaks back around with
the second set of keys takes the car and
we've got a tragedy so we can always
second-guess as far as shooting in the
arm and leg police are trained military
are trained to shoot center mass we
shoot in the middle of the body where it
will have the most stopping power and
stop the stop the attack and that's how
we train officers across the globe and
that's where we will hopefully we can
have one round or two rounds have the
kinetic energy take that person down and
we're not taking their life we're
shooting to stop we're not shooting to
kill back to the president's executive
order Joe calls will be banned except if
an officer's life is at risk that is
something that's also in the House bill
being written up this week by Democrats
and they want to get rid of what are
called no-knock warrants one led to
Brianna Taylor's much protested shooting
death in her home in Louisville Kentucky
in March we banned the tip show called
in Boston when I was the chief and Ed
Davis was the police commissioner we
thought it was something that was
harmful to suspects and harmful to our
officers that that you could get out of
control and in the very things we're
seeing play out could happen when we
don't want them to happen so that's
something I totally agree with I am you
know a big fan of not very limited
limited occasions what I allow a
no-knock search warrant I remember
cancelling my SWAT team doing no-knock
search warrants because I didn't want
the the danger I as a detective
commander I used to sit outside houses
for days at a time and I would have a
search warrant for the house I'd also
get a search warrant for the person the
target of my search warrant to take
their keys and go back to the house when
they weren't in it so anytime we can
avoid putting police in a high-risk
confrontation with our citizens who
might not know it's the police and might
not realize it and and defend their
property as they rightfully should I
would love to see that minimize as
possible now we've got an al Qaeda
terrorist cell and we've got to go in
there before you know they have the
ability to put some bombs together then
that decisions got to be made but we
should have a process that makes it and
very very limited on that we've got to
engage in training we've got to engage
in listening so we have a lot
folks in the community who are not happy
with the way we're policing and the last
thing we need to do is have police put
their backs up and say you know we're
not gonna listen to you this is the time
for law enforcement to listen and to
learn from why is the community doing
this why are they saying this how are we
able to better serve them the police are
the public and the public are the police
now getting law enforcement to the table
is hopefully going to be easier when
cama high heads prevail and we're not
throwing rocks and bottles at offices
who are trying to protect peaceful
protests the offices aren't taking a
position in this there is no I haven't
heard anyone saying you know they probe
police brutality the offices are trying
to protect protests at the same time
they are being subject to violence
they're being protests are being
hijacked by individuals who don't want a
peaceful protest but want to use it to
assault officers and loot and vandalize
property and we've got to work together
with those peaceful protesters to listen
to each other on both sides learn from
each other and develop how we want to go
forward you've heard the critics of the
police say that racism is just systemic
it's built-in and it has to be somehow
gotten out of policing in general do you
agree with that there's a systemic
problem there is race issues within
Police Department's just like there is
in the educational system in the
political system in media in boardrooms
in any aspect of society we have this
race and class issues there and we need
to address them head-on
Daniel Lenski former boston
superintendents in chief of police now
managing director of Kroll thank you
very much for joining us today thank you
this is dr. Rebecca grant with your Fox
News commentary
coming up President Trump went from
tough talk to high hopes for a deal with
North Korea we're prepared to start a
new history and we're ready to write a
new chapter between our nation's
but summits with kim jeong-hoon didn't
yield any lasting breakthroughs on the
North's nuclear program and now
pyongyang is picking on South Korea
announcing Tuesday night it will
redeploy troops to what had been tourism
and economic sites near the border this
after destroying what had been a symbol
of warming relations between the two
Koreas a liaison office meantime their
giant neighbor China just had its first
deadly confrontation since 1975 with
another nuclear power India troops had
been facing off for months along a
disputed border in Kashmir high in the
Himalayas President Trump had said he
offered to mediate the dispute but the
troops ended up fighting with India
reporting multiple casualties so why now
there have been a number of clashes near
what they call the line of actual
control it's in the mountains Ian
Bremmer is a political scientist and
author the president of Eurasia Group
and g0 media the Chinese sent additional
forces towards the border in part
because she shin ping is wanting to show
off his nationalist credentials you know
he's not had a great year right I mean I
mean as much as you know internationally
the Chinese are muscle-flexing and
saying you know we've got these masks
that we can sell you and give you and
you know we've got our supply chain back
up and running China's gonna be lucky to
avoid a recession this year to just have
flat growth there their consumer economy
is not rebounding the way the United
States consumer economy is right now and
keep in mind they covered this up this
pandemic we talk about that all the time
in the US but that's just not just for
the American people
that's for the Chinese people too I mean
they're suffering because she shouldn't
ping mishandled it so as a consequence
he has not wanted to look weak on any
national issue at home and
he is one where be hard for him to
simply back down does this seem like a
situation with both China and with North
Korea kind of making moves against South
Korea does it seem like a case of an
adversary trying to seize the
opportunity to make any kind of a move
during what could be perceived as a weak
moment for America if you're looking at
the crippling pandemic still going on
all the civil unrest lately
or am I making it too much about the US
and they actually have other things on
their mind strategically for India China
the United States is literally zero part
of this does not play a role has nothing
to do with it try it Trump said
literally nothing in response it would
not matter
I mean it's useful for Trump I mean
because he is looking to beat on the
Chinese for a bunch of reasons on
technology on Hong Kong on the
coronavirus I can see how politically it
would be useful for Trump if it turns
out there is evidence the Chinese are
actually in the wrong here that for
example these Indians that were killed
were clearly on their side of the border
I think Trump would make a big deal out
of that because Modi's pretty close to
Trump but remember Trump has not gone
off to Xi Jinping personally he goes
after China but he always says he likes
Xi Jinping he respects some he's a
strong leader he still says that despite
all the problems between the two
countries right now so I suspect Trump
is not gonna want to make much out of
this issue when you're talking about
North Korea there it's very clear
because Trump has made such a personal
effort to travel halfway around the
world meet twice with Kim jong-un big
summitry that gives the North Koreans a
lot more than the Americans get and now
the North Koreans are further
stockpiling on the nuclear side and
blowing up their relations with South
Korea specifically blaming the United
States and South Korea for part of this
so definitely that's more of a slap to
Trump it's interesting that the actual
steps that they've taken short-range
missile launches and now blowing up this
building
on the North Korean side of the border
that was supposed to facilitate
north-south interactions that's really
the steps they've taken up and slaps
against South Korea not against the
United States and our testing nukes
they're not testing ICBMs so I mean as
much as Kim jong-un is trying to show
that he's the guy that had that is
willing to call the shots here he
doesn't it's pretty clear he's not
looking to elicit a response or
escalation from Trump and how much of
this was actually orchestrated by Kim's
sister she was kind of the one who
articulated the threats toward South
Korea before they blew up that liaison
office right so it's pretty clear that
Kim jong-un is looking to further
elevate his sister kim yo-jong and she
is the one that has been pushing forward
the public announcements around this
decision but I you know that would make
perhaps if there is a succession or if
there are rumors of succession that are
being pushed by the south or by others
it would create more of a sense of this
is the way that the North Koreans are
going so the North Koreans I think are
trying to show don't try to take
advantage of the fact that we don't know
who's coming after Kim actually we do
have our ducks in a row but that doesn't
necessarily mean that she has become
more important or is actually calling
shots that Kim jong-un might not want
calling there's no basis to make that
argument is the regime under any kind of
you know coronavirus pressure like so
many parts of the world are because I
mean just it feels like they're picking
a fight with South Korea again why now
well he wants sanctions relief that's
pretty clear and you know even though
he's got better relations with China
South Korea and the United States than
he had a few years ago when Trump first
came into office that that hasn't led to
a lot of money for North Korea I mean
Trump met with them a couple of times
but the sanctions against North Korea
are still very much in place and so
only on the back of a major global
economic contraction trade is being
reduced you know you're not seeing ships
and planes going back and forth to North
Korea that were the way they were before
that makes smuggling a lot harder for
the North Koreans which is the way they
make a lot of their money so I mean I I
think it's this is purely economic
pressure and they are responding the
only way they know how which is stirring
the pot trying to make some headlines
long term
are there still prospects for progress
breakthroughs even with North Korea I
mean things they're just you know aside
from what they're doing now with South
Korea it just doesn't seem like there's
been any movement in in so long as you
say the sanctions remain in place though
it's hard to imagine I mean you know as
long as the United States is not
prepared to accept an existing nuclear
weapons program for North Korea I mean
they're clearly not going to get rid of
it they're not going to make steps
towards getting rid of it I think a
smaller deal I mean the the fact that
President Trump was prepared to
basically accept freeze for freeze they
freeze their nuclear program their
ballistic missile program they don't
develop an ICBM farther with inspections
we freeze our exercises our military
exercises in the region with the South
Koreans with the Japanese and you'll
remember the Trump said oh they're so
expensive I don't even know why we're
doing them I mean that's the kind of
thing that could have created more of
the diplomatic opening but it's really
hard to do under Trump because Trump
goes in and he wants to do these deals
himself and he doesn't have a lot of
time or patience for serious
multilateral diplomacy I mean you
remember this Iranian nuclear deal that
Obama got done which took an immense
amount of effort for John Kerry and
forth from the French and the Germans
and the UK and the Chinese and the
Russians too and after all of that it
was a pretty
small deal it only moved the needle
incrementally most American sanctions
were still on Iran the Iranians were
still in breach of United Nations
Security Council resolution on ballistic
missile development and testing they
were still supporting terrorist
organizations in the region and proxies
and the United States was still
squeezing the Iranian economy like hell
so I mean you know given how difficult
it is to make a breakthrough with a
country that is this much of a rogue
state where there's no trust between the
two sides the ability for a leader like
Trump to swoop in do a couple of
meetings and try to get something big
done really really hard why should
Americans care about conflicts like
these the tensions like between North
and South Korea or even between China
and India I mean the fact that countries
with nuclear weapons are involved and I
guess that should be enough of a concern
I mean the United States does care a lot
less about these crises than we did
historically and in part it's because
we're an energy exporter and a food
exporter and so I mean if you've got
major crises in other parts of the world
it's not affecting our economy and our
consumption as much as it might have
when there was a Middle East explosion
10 or 20 years ago you know I do think
that there are a lot of Americans that
look at conflicts like these and say I'm
not so sure I want the Americans playing
a role and you know everybody of course
was the media was was quick to make fun
of Trump's physical challenges walking
down that ramp at West Point but much
more significant was the fact that this
was a speech that made very clear that
the United States does not want to be
should not want to be America's
policeman anymore
engaging in battles and countries that
most Americans have no idea what they're
for and where they are and that that's
something that resonates much more
broadly with the American population
today than it did during the Cold War we
need to be aware of that the Chinese
issue because it
Claes it's such a big economy it matters
so much for for the globe for global
trade for exports to the Americans and
what we've actually pay for goods for
the fact that they buy a lot of American
paper which supports the American
ability to to lend the fact that that we
are getting a lot of our intellectual
property ripped off by the Chinese and
they're fighting us in technology those
things really matter to the average
Americans even if they don't necessarily
understand the transmission mechanism
the pocketbook issues their fundamental
well Ian Bremmer president of Eurasia
Group and g0
media thanks so much for your time
[Music]
download and make it hammer time with
Bill Hemmer
trey gowdy welcome so if the Department
is going to start issuing making public
investigations about people that you
don't even have enough information to
charge that is a slippery slope
subscribe and listen now by going to Fox
News podcasts dot-com subscribe to this
podcast at Fox News podcasts calm it's
time for your fox news commentary what's
on your mind
last week by a vote of 98 to 0 the
senate confirmed general charles CQ
Brown to be Air Force chief of staff
when ground takes over this summer he
will become the first African American
to lead a branch of our armed forces
grounds promotion doesn't erase problems
put in the spotlight by the May 25th
killing of George Cloyd but I'm glad to
see the military making history once
again on race and equal opportunity it
was back in 1947 when President harry s
truman ordered the full integration of
african americans into the military
since then several african americans
have served as generals and admirals
with some rising to the rank of four
stars the one you probably know best is
Army General Colin Powell we served as
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
from 1989 to 1993 but Powell was not
army chief of staff and that's what
makes Brown's confirmation unique as Air
Force chief of staff Brown will oversee
the budget to organize train and equip
that military service Brown serves as an
f-16 fighter pilot with basically a
perfect career resume including command
at the squadron level and above several
years commanding air operations against
Isis and two years leading Pacific Air
Forces where he dealt daily with North
Korea China and Russia but there's a
tinge to Brown's story for 36 years in
the Air Force
Brown has felt like he was quote living
in two worlds he revealed this in a raw
video posted on his official Twitter
account in early June Brown spoke out in
the wake of the death of George Floyd
and before the crucial Senate vote that
converted to this job that's very bold
here's some of what he said is he opened
up about his thoughts on race within his
incredibly successful Air Force career
Brown said I'm thinking about how my
sister and I were the only African
Americans in our entire elementary
school and trying to fit in I'm thinking
about my Air Force career where I was
often the only african-american in my
squadron or as a senior officer the only
african-american in the room the hard
grading of Air Force combat aviation
made brown's career fighter pilots like
brown literally live or die on merit but
Brown also dealt with pressures along
the way because of his race Brown
recalled evenings at the officer's club
with my squadron being told by other
African American officers that I wasn't
black enough because it wasn't spending
more time with them the general spoke of
the pressure I felt to perform
error-free especially from supervisors
who I perceived expected less from me as
an african-american I've never heard a
senior military officer talk like that
Brown is comfortable with putting
himself on the line as a leader he
doesn't claim to have all the answers
he just said quote I want to have the
wisdom and knowledge to lead and
difficult times like these generals ZQ
Brown we wish you luck I'm dr. Rebecca
grant for Fox News
you've been listening to the Fox News
run down to hear the podcast version of
this program go to Fox News podcasts
comm and for all the latest news go to
Fox news.com
[Music]
I love Fox News click the subscribe
button to get more of the news and
opinion you trust and click the FoxNews
rundown playlist for the latest episodes